[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMIE THOMSON: My
name is Jamie Thomson.
I am an engineer for a company
called Dunnhumby in the UK.
We're a big GCP customer.
And we've been using Dataproc
for a couple of years now.
So really, today's
session could be
retitled, "Our Journey with
Google Cloud Platform."
I'm going to talk
a lot about what
we've been using, how we do
a lot of stuff that we do,
especially using Dataproc.
And I'm quite lucky, because
I'm here representing the team
that I work for, which
within Dunnhumby is
a team called core technology.
It's our job to provide
infrastructure and services
to the rest of the company.
A bunch of very
smart people, and I'm
lucky enough to be
here representing
that team of about
25 people today.
So what do Dunnhumby do exactly?
I want to just level set.
So I want people to
understand what it is we do,
because that will feed into
the rest of the presentation.
So we're a customer-first
data science company.
We believe if our customers--
if our clients put
their customers first,
and through that they
can drive loyalty,
through that they can drive
long-term sustainable profit.
We've been doing this
for about 25 years
now, long before the term big
data had ever been coined.
And we're wholly owned
by Tesco in the UK.
And they are also
our biggest client.
And we've been behind the
success of Tesco's club card
loyalty scheme for
some years now.
So at a high level,
we do a couple
of things for our clients.
So firstly, we provide
consultancy over the data
that they provide to us.
Clients will ask us
tactical questions like,
why am I losing very
price sensitive customers
to my competitor?
Or they'll ask us
strategic questions,
such as, what would
be my best media
strategy for return investment
over the next four to five
years?
And in both of these cases, we
try and answer those questions
through a combination of
data and data science.
Over the past 25
years, we've built--
we've got a lot of experience,
and as you can imagine,
we've come across some
common problems quite a lot.
We've built up a
software portfolio
to address some of these issues.
So we have products around
category management, price
and promotions, and media.
So our category
assortment offering,
which helps typically
our retail clients
decide what to put
on the shelves.
Our media offering
helps people--
helps our clients decide
who to target with offers
and when to do that.
And price and promotions
helps our clients
make decisions such
as, what promotions
should I be putting on in my
stores in the couple of months?
Things like that.
So this short slide
covers where we work.
So we're all over the globe.
We've got 78 retail clients
and over 1,000 consumer
packaged goods clients.
We manage data for about 800
customers of our retailers.
And we've got a data corpus
of about 44 billion baskets
that our data scientists
work against every day.
So I just want to
go in a nutshell
what Dunnhumby kind
of do and how we work.
So clients will send
their data to us.
And when they do that, we will
assign a team of data engineers
to that client.
And it's their responsibility
to take the incoming data,
transform it into what we call a
common data model that can then
be used by our products,
and by our services,
by our data scientists
throughout the company.
So that's the role of
our data engineers.
We have products which consume
that common data model.
And we have data
scientists which
provide consultancy
services running algorithms
over that common data model.
And finally, we
deliver services back
to our clients in the way of
APIs and data visualizations.
So I said we've been in
this business for 25 years,
but our business has been
changing over the past five
years.
We typically sought very
long multi-year engagements
with our clients,
but we're finding
that was becoming really
unpalatable to a lot
of our prospects.
Clients really wanted
shorter engagements with us.
And they were looking for
a lot more flexibility
of how we can actually
provide what we provide.
Our technology stack
was very proprietary.
It was best of breed, which
is another word for saying
it was very expensive.
And we hosted all of our
own infrastructure as well.
So we have four data centers--
two in the US, two in the UK.
And we've got about 4
petabytes of data stored
across those data centers.
So we made a conscious
decision to move
to open source and cloud.
Open source because it was
cheaper, much more flexibility.
And cloud because buying
hardware for short client
engagements was never really
going to be feasible for us.
So we're about halfway through
our journey of migrating
all our clients to the cloud.
We hope to in a
couple of years fully
deprecate all of
our data centers.
The technology stack
that we're using
is what I've put
on the slide here.
So we were using Oracle
Exadata for storage,
SAS for data processing,
and Redwood Cronacle
as our scheduling tool.
All three of which, best
of breed, very expensive,
and they cost us a lot of money.
So we made the--
through a program of work,
which we call tech renewal,
we made a lot of changes to how
we deliver stuff and the tools
that we use to
actually deliver it.
So we made a big
investment in Python
as our chosen language
for our data scientists.
We made a big bet
on Apache Spark.
We adopted Spark when it
was around the 1.6 version.
I think since then it's proved
to be the kind of de facto
tool for big data processing.
So we're very pleased with
what Spark's doing for us.
We have adopted Apache
Airflow as a workflow tool.
For those that don't know, this
is a scheduling workflow tool
that came out of Airbnb.
And we use Jupyter Notebooks.
Our data scientists
use Jupyter Notebooks.
We provide them too as
part of the infrastructure
I'm going to demonstrate today.
And we made a big bet
on Terraform as well.
Terraform is a tool from a
company called HashiCorp.
And what it does is allow you
to manage your infrastructure
as code.
So we're using that
to deploy everything
that I'm going to be
talking about today.
And I've got a demo
a little bit later
that will talk a
little bit about that.
We're using Grafana,
another open source
tool for visualizing
monitoring data.
And finally, the other
big bet that we made
was choosing GCP as our
preferred cloud provider.
And as part of
that, Dataproc has
become the cornerstone
of everything
that we're doing on GCP.
And we've been using that
for about two years now.
So tech renewal has
provided Dunnhumby
with quite a lot of benefits.
We now have a modern
tech stack, the things
I was just talking about.
Massive reduction in cost,
mostly through the lack--
we don't have to pay
license fees anymore.
Better provisioning.
We can provision infrastructure
for new clients a lot quicker
than we could ever
do that in the past.
Much more scalable platform.
We can dial it up
and down as we need.
We have a lot more
hosting options.
Previously, all we could
do was host clients
in the US or the UK.
We can now host them wherever
Google has got a data center.
Much more robust security.
We build on top of Google's
investments in that area.
And we benefit from that.
We're also finding a lot
more opportunities from this
as well.
There's a lot more
clients out there
who want to be on the
cloud and want to come
on this journey with us.
And it's providing a lot more
partnering opportunities for us
as well.
OK.
So that's enough spiel about
what Dunnhumby actually do,
and what we are.
I want to talk more now
about the real meat of what
we're doing.
And this is something we call
transient Dataproc clusters.
Google will refer to it as a
ephemeral Dataproc clusters.
I don't know why we called
it something different,
but transient data clusters is
how we refer to it internally.
Basically it means when
we're not using Dataproc,
we turn it off.
That's a very simple premise.
And this presentation really
talks about how we do that.
So there is a blog post,
the link at the bottom,
which is from
Google that explains
exactly how to do this.
So a flexible way to deploy
Hive on Cloud Dataproc.
And the way it works
is you can imagine
you might have multiple clients
that actually want to use
Hive running upon Dataproc.
So that might be Spark clients.
It might be MapReduce clients.
So in this diagram
here, you'll see
we have two of these
transient clusters,
or ephemeral clusters
as Google call them.
I took this diagram from
the blog post actually.
And each of those clusters is
running Hive, Hive metastore
service.
And it runs a component
called Cloud SQL proxy, which
is a Google-provided
component that allows the Hive
service running on
that ephemeral cluster
to connect to a Hive metastore.
And that Hive metastore
is running in Cloud SQL,
Google's Cloud SQL offering.
Specifically, we use MySQL.
The data itself that
we process and we store
is stored in Google Cloud
Storage in storage buckets.
We don't store the data
on the cluster itself,
because as I was saying, when
we're not using those clusters,
we want to get rid of them.
Obviously, we need
the data to persist.
So we use Google Cloud Storage
buckets in order to do that.
So we offer transient
clusters for both
of those types of
groups of users
that we talked about before.
So our data engineers
and data scientists.
We group all the things that
we deploy into components.
We have a component
we call data platform.
It's specifically
what I work on.
And what we provide
to our data engineers
are these short-lived clusters.
They're clusters
that you spend up
to do a specific piece of work.
And then you shut down
when you're not using them.
The way we do that is we
allow our data engineers
to provision clusters via
a series of custom Airflow
operators that we
wrote ourselves.
And so our data engineers
use Airflow as an interface
to create these clusters and
create their retail jobs,
and then shut the clusters down.
By using clusters for a
single use, for a single job,
that provides a great
advantage to us,
because we can actually
label those cluster resources
according to what they are
actually going to be used for.
So a data engineer
might be doing
some work around
dimension processing
or transaction aggregation or
feature generation, something
like that.
If we can label what that
cluster is actually used for,
we can actually get
a fine grained cost
analysis of how much
it actually cost us
to carry out those functions.
And you'll see that
a little bit later.
Finally, we use a feature
called Scheduled Deletion.
This is something
that Google provide.
It's an option.
When you create a
Dataproc cluster that
allows you to specify
the amount of time
that the cluster should
be idle for before Google
will automatically shut it down
for you, which is really handy.
Typically, we set
this to 30 minutes.
I think the minimum time you
can set it to is 10 minutes.
But basically, as soon
as the cluster is idle--
it's not being used anymore--
Google will shut that
down on our behalf.
And the way they do that--
so this is the command to
actually create a cluster.
And there is an option,
which is max idle.
You set that to whatever
duration you need,
and it will shut it down for
you when it's not being used.
You'll see it's in
beta at the moment.
It's been in beta for
quite a long time.
But if anyone went
to the session
yesterday, Chris
Crosby's session,
somebody asked about this.
And they basically said,
yes, it's effectively
been GA for a long time.
They just haven't got round to
switching off the beta tag yet.
But it's there.
We've been using
it for a long time.
And it's been very
successful for us.
OK.
So that was talking
about the clusters
that we provide to
our data engineers.
Now I'll talk a little bit
about our data scientists.
They have a slightly different
need to our data engineers.
They will need to carry
out ad hoc analyses.
And for that reason, we always
need to have clusters available
for them to do their work.
It takes two or three minutes
to spin up a Dataproc cluster.
So what we never want to do
is leave our data scientists
sitting around waiting
for a cluster to spin up.
We need to give them much
more immediate access to that.
So what we provide for them
is auto-scaling clusters.
These are clusters
that will increase--
the number of nodes will
increase as the load
on those clusters increases.
So the more users
that are using it,
the bigger those
clusters will get.
We'll talk a little
bit on the next slide
about how we actually do that.
We also offer Jupyter.
So every single one
of our data sciences
has the ability to visit
a portal that we provide
and spin up their own dedicated
Jupyter Notebook running
inside a Kubernetes pod that
we manage on their behalf.
So there's no need
for a data scientist
to install anything
on their machine.
We provide it for them.
All they need is a
browser that will
enable them to use Jupyter.
And of course, then Jupiter
offers Python and R.
So our data scientists
have the option
of using Python or R for the
stuff that they're doing.
So a slide specific to
auto-scaling clusters.
So you may be aware that
Google have got a feature--
I think it's in
beta at the moment--
an auto-scaling feature.
We're not actually using that.
We actually built
our own tool, which
we call Tidebell, which will
actually provide auto-scaling
for us.
And the way it
works is it monitors
cluster utilization via the
YARN API that every cluster has.
And if it notices that
memory pressure is getting
above a certain
threshold, it will
start to add more nodes into
that cluster dynamically.
It uses preemptible
nodes to do that.
What are preemptible nodes?
Well, Dataproc is built
upon Google's Compute Engine
service.
And they've got an
offering on Compute Engine
called preemptible machines.
And what they are,
they're standard VMs.
However, they do--
they allow Google,
when they need data
center capacity,
to take that away from what
they're being used for.
So Google will actually
take those down away from us
with about a five
minute warning.
But that means they're
really well scheduled
to systems which are resilient
to clusters going away.
And Spark is really
resilient to that.
So it's great for us to use
these preemptible nodes.
The main benefit is,
obviously, they're
a heck of a lot cheaper.
So I saw on a slide yesterday
from the Dataproc team
that you can get up
to 80% cost savings
just through using
preemptible nodes.
So that's pretty much
why we want to use them.
We do expect to replace
Tidebell in the very
near future with Dataproc's
own auto-scaling feature.
That's currently in beta.
And aside from that, I think
last week they also announced
a new feature,
which is currently
in alpha, which is called
Enhanced Flexible Mode.
I think it is EFM.
And what that will
allow you to do
is make it a lot easier
to use preemptible nodes,
because what it actually does
is persist the state of the jobs
to HDFS before those nodes
actually get shut down.
So really, we do have some
issues with preemptible nodes.
Obviously, if a node's going
away when a job is running,
that's not great.
But this new EFM features should
be really valuable for us.
I'm actually seeing Mikayla
in the back nodding,
so I think she's-- if you want
to know anything about it,
Mikayla in the back knows a
lot more about it than I do.
So I said we use Grafana for
visualizing monitoring data.
And this is a
screenshot from Grafana.
So this shows activity
across our whole state,
across our Dataproc state--
pardon me-- over
a 24-hour period.
What we're looking at
here is the blue line
is the number of
nodes that we actually
have active on Dataproc at
a particular point in time.
So you see when we actually
took this screenshot,
we had 105 nodes currently
active at that time.
The yellow line is the
number of primary workers.
That means the non-preemptible
nodes that we have running.
And the red shade
there at the bottom
is the number of preemptions
that actually occur.
So this is the number
of times in a day
that Google will take compute
resources away from us.
So I just want to
talk a little bit
about how our data
scientists actually
work on this infrastructure.
So typically, a data scientist
will require the ability
to do ad hoc analysis-- so
carrying out investigations
upon the data that we provide
in that common data model
I talked about earlier.
They'll do that upon our
auto-scaling clusters,
because that's actually
why to provide them.
And that's their
reason for existence.
And we also encourage
our data scientists
to use sample data sets
rather than full data sets
for doing exploratory work
for model training and things
like that.
The reason being that if
they're using full data
sets, A, it's going
to cost us more,
because we're going
to be spinning up
more nodes to do it.
And we do have a danger that if
many data scientists are using
a cluster at any one time, it
is possible for a particular job
to max out that cluster.
And that will impact
anybody else using it.
So we do encourage
them to use sample data
sets wherever possible.
So when they've done that,
they've done a lot of work.
They decide on some work
that they need to do.
We would then
encourage them to take
that work they've
done in Jupyter
and turn that into
a job that can
be run on one of the
short-lived clusters
that I talked about earlier.
So the difference between
our short-lived clusters,
which have the
scheduled deletion
option, and our long-lived
clusters that use auto-scaling.
So they'll use the auto-scaling
clusters for investigation,
and they'll run
production-ready jobs
upon our short-lived clusters.
So what we're looking
at here is a report
that we built in
Google Data Studio.
So this sits on top
of our billing data
that Google provides to us.
And that billing data
is stored in BigQuery.
So a number of
things I just want
to draw your attention to here.
When we actually use
these Dataproc clusters,
we use labeling
upon those clusters
to tell us various
things about what
they are going to be used for.
So for example, the data-- we
can slice and dice this data
by the client, the date that
the cluster is being used for,
because every
cluster is dedicated
to a particular client.
The project that
it's been used in.
The components.
Now, what do I
mean by component?
So I talked earlier about
how we have our data platform
component that we offer
to data engineers.
We have our analyst
platform that we
offer to data scientists.
So we can slice and dice the
data by those two things.
We can filter and slice
and dice by the machine
type and the number of nodes.
So this is really useful,
because we can actually see--
we allow our data engineers
to know the cost of actually
running specific jobs.
And they can test that using
different node configurations
and see whether
it's cost effective
or not to actually use
more nodes in that cluster.
And finally, this is the
real useful part of it.
What we've allowed people to do
is label the specific workload
that they're using
that cluster for.
So as I talked about
before, a data engineer
might be doing things like
damage and processing,
or transaction aggregation,
or feature generation.
And if they actually
label that cluster--
we give them tools
to actually do that--
we can actually get
very specific costings
about how much it costs
to actually run that job.
So you see in this
example I'm filtering on--
I used the word
workload earlier.
We actually call it a purpose.
So filtering on a
purpose, a smoke test.
So this is a test that we
run across our whole state.
What it does is very simple.
It spins up a Dataproc cluster.
It runs some jobs upon it.
And then it shuts the
cluster down after.
So we can actually get a
cost for how much it actually
costs us to actually run
one of those smoke tests.
So there's an example here.
You can see it actually costs
us $0.18 every time-- well,
roughly $0.18--
every time we spend up a
cluster, run a couple of jobs,
and shut it down.
So that sort of fine grained
analysis is fantastic for us.
We could never do that
when we were running Hadoop
in our own data
center, because it
was shared between multiple
clients, multiple engineers.
Here we're actually having
single use clusters.
And we can actually get the cost
of spinning one of those up,
which is really
advantageous for us.
And you can see over
the past few months,
if you look in the
bottom right-hand corner,
that's cost us about $142
over the past five years--
past five months, just running
that particular smoke test.
So in a single day,
what do we actually do?
So look at the lower
numbers, first of all.
We run these services
for 35 clients currently.
That's about half
of our client base.
I said we're about halfway
through our cloud migration.
So we've got about
35 clients running
in GCP and approximately
300 terabytes stored
for those clients.
On any particular day we
use about 17,000 hours
of Compute Engine time.
Our particular hour is using
a core and a Compute Engine
instance for one hour.
So 17,000 plus hours
in a particular day.
Thanks to our auto-scaling
feature, and thanks
to our short-lived clusters,
which we encourage our data
engineers to spin up as and
when they need, we actually,
on the particular
day we measured this,
we created 2,971 nodes.
That's physical-- not physical.
Virtual machines
running Compute Engine
being used for the
purposes of Dataproc.
525 of them got preempted.
So that gives you some sort of
indication about the preemption
rates that we're
seeing from using
preemptible nodes on
our Dataproc clusters,
on our auto-scale clusters.
So that whole lot--
17,000 hours costs us
approximately $7,600 a day.
I'll let you figure out whether
that's expensive or not.
We're pretty happy with
what that's costing us,
because as I say, that cost is
spread across those 35 clients.
And we have approximately
175 data scientists
on any particular
day using Jupyter
on our short-lived
clusters accessing
that data that's sitting in
Google Cloud Storage buckets.
So this is the money slide
in more ways than one.
This depicts the cost of
actually providing the services
that we provide to
just one single client
over a 12-month period.
So I didn't include the y-axis,
because the numbers themselves
are not that important.
But I think you see the
profile is what I really
want to draw your attention to.
And you'll see in
August last year
we had a huge downturn in the
actual expenditure of cost
to service client.
And the reason for
that is very simply
that's when we introduced
transient clusters
for this client.
So a very real
depiction of the cost
saving that we're getting
from using transient clusters.
The spiking workloads
that you see over
to the right-hand side that have
increased over the past three
or four months, that's
because our analysts,
our data scientists
are now get much more
familiar with the platform.
And they're starting to run much
more production ready workloads
on this.
And it's spiky because
we're encouraging
them to use those
short-lived clusters that I
talked about earlier on.
So a lot of people
ask, OK, that's great.
You're using Dataproc
for things like that.
It seems to be
pretty successful.
But you're on GCP.
Why not just use BigQuery?
I've had a lot of people from
Google asking me the same thing
this week as well.
So there's a few reasons.
GCP is our preferred
cloud provider,
but that doesn't mean
we're always going
to be running stuff on GCP.
It's not available everywhere.
We do have clients in
China and in Russia.
And we do find in
some certain cases
that our clients may
want to dictate the cloud
provider to us.
Some people we've
found are actually not
happy we're on GCP.
And in those cases, we have to
provide a different provider.
So basically, we strive
to be cloud portable,
but we're not cloud agnostic.
We want to be able
to move our workloads
across different clouds.
And we're making a bet on
open source technologies
like Hadoop.
And Spark has been
a driver of that.
And our other big bet that
we've made technically
has been around
Kubernetes as well.
So adopting those open
source technologies hopefully
will allow us to
move our workflows
across different
clouds in the future.
And obviously, the Anthos
announcement a couple of days
ago is going to be
very interesting to us.
All that said, we do use
BigQuery for some things.
I talked about how we use
it for our billing data.
That drives the report you
saw a couple of slides back.
We also have some
direct-to-consumer offerings
that we have as well.
So we have a receipt scanning
mobile app called HuYu.
It's only in the
UK at the moment,
but basically it
provides loyalty rewards
to customers who want to
actually scan their receipts.
And all the data for that gets
stored in BigQuery as well.
Because that's a
direct-to-consumer offering,
it's essentially the client
is Dunnhumby ourselves.
So we can host that
wherever we want, and we
choose to put that in BigQuery.
I want to talk a little bit
about the solution architecture
that we have within
our core technology.
This is essentially
the architecture
that we deploy for
each of our clients.
So the base component is
something we call network.
That basically consists of
VPC network and Cloud DNS.
So we provision DNS
A records and CNAME
records for that client.
On top of that, we deploy
a component we call base.
This provides an
external proxy so
that we can get to the outside
world should we need to.
An SSH gateway so that we
as engineers can actually
get onto the
infrastructure itself
should we need to for
investigation, for maintenance,
anything like that.
And we also provide a single
sign-on authentication proxy
as well.
That's all part of
our base components.
On top of that, we
have a component
we call Hive metastore.
And this is what I was
talking about a bit earlier
in the talk where we
use Google's Cloud SQL
offering to host the
Hive metastore that
will get used by our
transient ephemeral clusters.
So that is a component
we deploy on its own.
It essentially is a MySQL
database running in Cloud SQL.
On top of that, we have our
data platform component,
which is the thing
I said I worked on.
This is where we provide
short-lived clusters
to our data engineers.
We do that through a
combination of Dataproc,
storage buckets, Airflow.
And we also provide Jupyter
instances to our data engineers
as well.
On top of that, our
analyst platform
I talked about before, again,
we're using transient clusters.
We're using-- our
also-scaled clusters
using our Tidebell tool.
And we provide Jupyter
running on top of Kubernetes
to our data scientists as well.
We also run our various
products on top of this as well.
So that's our architecture.
The way we actually
deploy that is
across two separate projects,
two separate GCP projects.
We have a project
dedicated for hosting
our runtime infrastructure
and our projects dedicated
to hosting data essentially.
So a state.
So why do we do that?
It prevents-- it provides quite
a lot of advantages actually.
So we could keep our long-lived
state in a dedicated project
and keep our short-lived
runtime in a separate project.
And really, the key to
this is segregation.
So it's segregation
of permissions
around IAM, segregation of data
retention privacy policies,
and it also makes it easier
for disaster recovery as well.
So essentially, we
take the architecture
that I showed a
couple of slides back,
and we deploy that
across those two projects
that we dedicate per client.
So essentially, we have multiple
instances of this architecture
running across our GCP state.
So why do we do it?
Why do we have this single
tenant deployment model?
Previously, when we run
everything on-premises
in our own data center, we
didn't have a single tenant
deployment model.
We had very big clusters.
And we shared them
between multiple clients.
Now we're in the cloud.
We can use a single
deployment model.
And the reason really is
one of segregation, really.
It's keeping things
separate that don't
need to be in the same place.
It's a lot simpler for
us to assign access
for a client to actually
access our infrastructure.
We can just control that
with the natural boundary
that GCP project provides.
It's a lot simpler
for us to operate.
We don't need to
worry about using
Kerberos or anything like that.
Cost transparency is
a big factor for us.
If we want to actually
see the cost of serving
a particular client, it's
very easy to do that,
because the billing data
can all be grouped up
to a particular project,
or a couple of projects.
So we can see very
easily the cost
of actually serving a client.
And you saw that on
an earlier slide.
The other big advantage
that it provides
is the ability to
scale from zero.
So what do I mean by that?
If you think about
how we work, we
will sign a client to
do some work for them.
We'll provision two
projects on their behalf.
At that point,
there's essentially
nothing in those projects.
There's no data.
There's no runtime components.
And none of our data
scientists or data engineers
will actually have access to it.
So literally, we start.
We have nothing.
It makes it a lot easier
to scale that up as
and when we need.
We never had the
capability to do that when
we were on-premises because
we were using share clusters.
So we had to provision
massive clusters
in advance of actually
signing our clients
before we actually know that
we were going to have them.
So it makes it a lot easier for
us to provide infrastructure
to brand new clients.
That's really the
meat of the talk.
I've been talking about
transient clusters,
auto-scale clusters,
and the architecture
that we use to provide
that to our clients.
Now, what I've done is
provide a project on GitHub
that really demonstrates
a lot of how we do this.
So what this is is a project
that will use Terraform code
to deploy the parts
of the architecture
that I just demonstrated.
And specifically,
what it will do
is deploy those transient
clusters for us.
So this is a screenshot
from the Read Me
that's part of that project.
Essentially, if you want to
run this, all you need to do
is clone the repo,
run G Cloud in it,
which will establish which
projects you actually
want to-- which GCP projects
you want to deploy this into.
You enable a couple of services.
Specify the project.
You have to create
a Cloud Storage
bucket, which is what Terraform
will use to store its state.
So Terraform needs
to keep a record
of what has been deployed.
It does that in
a storage bucket.
And then there's a
makefile in there which
will actually show you how to--
which will actually deploy
this on your behalf.
So you could clone that, create
a project, run the apply.
That whole thing should
take about five minutes.
I don't want to demo
it today because we
don't want to stare at a command
line for about five minutes.
But if you want to
see how this works
and how we set this
up using Terraform,
this is a really
good way to do it.
And when you're finished you
could just run make destroy,
and it'll tear the
whole thing down again.
One thing you can
do with Terraform
is actually visualize
all the components
that it's going
to deploy for you.
And this is the output of
running that Terraform graph
command.
The command in the
bottom right-hand corner
shows you exactly what
command you need to run,
which will generate
this graph for you.
And just to call out
a few things on here,
the yellow boxes are
the network components
that it will deploy for you.
So we deploy a network, a sub
network, and various firewalls
that enable the different
components to talk
to each other.
We deploy a Google
storage bucket which
will actually store the data.
That's the purple component
you can see at the bottom.
The red components are
the Hive metastore.
That's for the Cloud
SQL instance that
is hosting the Hive metastore.
And a SQL use enables
us to access that.
The blue are the ephemeral
clusters themselves,
the transient clusters.
We create-- this project
will create two of them
for you, both of them
pointing at that shared Hive
metastore, which really is
the crux of this presentation,
to be honest.
And then on top of
that, the green boxes
are some jobs that we run
on top of those clusters.
And as I say, deploying
this whole thing
and running those jobs
takes four or five minutes.
Then you can tear it all
down again afterwards.
So it's a really
good demonstration
of how we do what
we do and how you
can use these ephemeral clusters
using a shared Hive metastore.
So before I came
out here, I said
I work with a team of about 25.
So I sent an email
round to everybody
I worked with that said,
can you just give me
a grab bag of things I can
talk about at the end, which
will come under the
banner of lessons learned?
So here's a few things that
my colleague sent to me.
I'm just going to go
through them one by one.
So this shared Hive
metastore is great
because it allows us to use
these ephemeral clusters.
But it does make
upgrades very difficult,
because we've got to coordinate
teams of data scientists,
teams of data engineers,
and our infrastructure teams
to make sure that we're not
stepping on anybody's toes
when we try to
upgrade that stuff.
We have to upgrade
everything at the same time.
We're working with Google to
make that a little bit easier.
We're hoping to anyway.
But yeah, it is a bit of a pain
point for us at the moment.
We recommend if
you're going to do
this you peg Dataproc to a
particular specific minor
release.
You don't have to do that.
You can specify a
particular Dataproc version,
a major release
version if you want.
But we have seen
that doing that--
and then we'll deploy the
latest minor release for you--
we have seen occasions where
the minor release changes some
of the scripts that we run, some
of the initialization scripts
do break.
So be careful with that.
Peg it to a minor
release if you can.
StackDriver logs can become
very chatty, grow very quickly.
And they can become
very expensive.
StackDriver's not cheap.
Certainly not if
you're using a lot
and you're throwing
lots of logs into it.
So use log exclusions within
StackDriver if you can.
And configure your
log4j properties
so it's not being too chatty.
I said we're using
Terraform, and we are.
It's been great for us.
But be aware that the Terraform
providers or the Google
specific Terraform
provider generally lags
what's available in the SDK.
So you might be using
features in G Cloud,
for example, that are currently
not supported in Terraform.
We have experienced
that a few times.
And we have made upstream
commits to the Terraform Google
provider.
But it has been a
bit of a pain for us.
In shared clusters,
users can easily
crash the master nodes where
driver runs on the master,
so change the default
deploy mode to cluster.
If you're familiar
with using Spark,
you have two deployment
modes-- client and cluster.
Where we're using-- where
we have shared clusters,
it's quite easy for
one data scientist
to run a nefarious job
which actually brings
the whole cluster to its knees.
So for that reason, run with
a deployment mode of cluster,
and you minimize the
chances of that happening.
More lessons learned.
YARN application
masters can fail
if scheduled on preempted nodes.
So I explained how
preempted nodes
are all about how Google
could actually take
that resource away from us.
So running masters on
that is not a good idea.
You can get around this
by using node labeling.
And I believe there's
also a Dataproc config
option which has come out which
prevents this from happening.
So use that.
And I can see Mikayla in
the back nodding as well.
So happy to use that.
The default Spark
config in Dataproc
can cause an individual
to max out the cluster.
Yes.
So we're using these
shared clusters.
If you don't tune the initial
configuration options,
we were seeing particular
jobs that our data scientists
were running were
actually bringing clusters
to their knees.
So be careful with the
default memory configuration
you apply to those jobs.
Users need the
Spark and YARN UIs,
but hard to make
secure and available
via our authentication proxy.
Anyone that's used
Spark will tell you
that the YARN and the
Spark UIs are incredibly
useful for diagnosing
issues within those jobs,
particularly if you've got
skew in your Spark jobs.
So we've had a lot
of hassle making
those UIs available via the
single sign-on authentication
proxy that we have.
So something to be aware of.
Make sure you get those
working as early as possible.
Conda is a useful
tool for building
consistent Python environments
across Dataproc and Jupyter
Notebooks.
So we need to make sure that the
same Python libraries that we
deployed to Dataproc
are the same that we
used in our Jupyter
Notebooks as well.
Conda is a useful
tool for doing that.
And finally, GCS retention
policies on temporary data
sets.
So we provide specific temporary
areas, so Google storage
buckets, that our
data scientists
can use for temporary storage.
And you can set retention
policies on those
so that data gets cleared down
after a certain amount of time.
We actually saw an
occasion last week
where the usage of one
of our particular clients
jumped from 17 terabytes
to 36 terabytes overnight.
And it's basically because
one of our data scientists
had dropped a load of data into
one of these temporary staging
areas.
That happened on a Friday.
By the end of Monday,
that would automatically
get cleaned up again because
of the retention policy
that we put on those
temporary areas.
Right.
I am done.
Thank you very much for
attending, everybody.
Ubiquitous slide about
providing feedback if you could.
I'd certainly really
appreciate it.
I've got about 10 minutes left.
So if anybody wants to stick
around, I'll take questions.
And thank you once
again for coming along.
I hope it was useful.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]